Mike it's Ross how you doing buddy I'm
giving you the silent treatment right
now for what you said about my looks for
saying that you're not a top five Mike
do you think you are a top five person
in the world in terms of looks for men
when you put it that way actually I
can't be mad at ya absolutely right i
thought top [ __ ] you yes i'm not either
i don't know who I was talking about it
I wish I knew by the way Mike I always
want to want to pronounce your last name
like the actress who's in um oh she's in
so many different movies yeah Janeane
Garofalo but what's the movie where
they're at oh oh I'll figure it out I'll
figure it out while I ask you a football
question what was it was it um uh what's
the cats and dogs movie know what I'm
talking about Jim Carrey I think was in
it she's Oh cable guy cable guy yeah she
was she was she wouldn't give him a fork
or spoon yes there were no utensils in
medieval times hence there are no
utensils at medieval times and then she
offers him as you would you like
something to drink water beer diet
Pepsi's like oh they didn't have you
been but they had diet I love that
there's one of my favorite life and then
she's like I just work here dude right I
just work here so for clarity's sake
I've been pronouncing it right correct
gara follow well you've been off your
right as we pronounce it but actually
the traditional pronunciation the
European pronunciation would be would be
garofalo but you know you take things
you switch letters around you
Americanize it we accent different
syllables over here now we're getting
into word etymology which is probably
not what people here but when you
Americanize it so you said it right the
American Way really the true way to say
it is garofalo the way they say it over
Italy got it kind of like Janeane
Garofalo there you go you got it right
so either way is actually correct uh
either way if everybody's right
everybody get surprised everybody went
by logic soccer you know who doesn't
the prize is Josh Gordon there you go
about that segue right there I'm really
getting good this I gotta Pat myself on
the back what do we know hear me give me
that give me the latest you're the one
that broke the story yesterday what
exactly happened and when yeah well look
it's when you get this when you get to
the point where you're suspended for a
year and a couple of guys have fallen
into that recently Josh Gordon justin
blackmon Daryl Washington these kinds of
suspensions where it's we say ho gai
suspended for a year but really it's
suspended for a year minimum and then
the Commissioner has to reinstate you so
he's in this mode where he's trying to
get reinstated there's a slogan 60-day
window it had been extended nobody knew
why and I was able to discover that
there was this you know failed test now
I sort of used the word failed loosely a
little bit because it's not like oh the
threshold for marijuana is 35 nanograms
per milliliter and he was at seven it
was actually a lot lower but it was
diluted and when you have a diluted
sample you know thought that counts as
they failed yet according to the NFL
substance abuse policy now the one thing
that people have been asking me the most
the last day is well hold on he's in
this you know suspended needs to be
reinstatement but he failed the test so
why are you saying that there's a chance
that he's going to play this year and I
think there's a couple of reasons here
now this is the point where I'm starting
to read the tea leaves and speculate on
my own a couple things one we've had
guys suspended for much worse than have
been back on the field sooner then then
Josh Gordon has recently and you know
I'm talking about the geyser the
off-field incidents oh I think the end
of Saul's a little bit sensitive to that
and to I think that this speech to the
fact that that Gordon's been pretty good
for the last year and it's when you get
suspended it's not like you disappear
for a year you come back the NFL go oh
hey how did your year ago they've been
tracking in the hallway they've been
testing in the whole way so I I do
believe the fact that they're still
keeping him alive right now tells you
they actually got a pretty good job over
the last year and they made willing to
look past this one miss sector but
that's what i don't understand Mike
because ever
the other aspect of the policy it's
pretty cut and dry you know the first
time you fail you're suspended this game
this mini games the second time it's
this many games so with him being
suspended for a year any test positive
again is that not written in the policy
anywhere that okay when you're spending
for a year you test positive again it's
automatically another year there's
reported out now that all they wanted to
do is joyce's if he just stays clean the
next two or three months we'll let them
play this yeah i'm totally confused that
well you know what i was confused myself
um and when i was reporting the story
it's so funny i saw some stuff yes
yesterday speculating that oh it's funny
that this came out on the same day that
the report was out that he was living
with johnny manziel anna and i'm
thinking i've been working on this since
friday and and part of what i was
working on was trying to clarify okay
well you're suspended a year there's
nothing in the policy that says okay you
get you you test positive you're gone
for another year like like you said I
mean that was my initial thought was
okay that's the positive he can be time
for another year but as I was checking
this out and talking to people reading
the policy by self I fail astray might
let me go back so when so when black men
and Washington got suspended for a year
or a year minimum and then we never
really heard about every now and then
you hear about him via a reporter who
said you know hey I asked Dave Caldwell
with the Jaguars or Steve kind with the
Cardinals you know what's the latest on
black men or Washington they said well
you know status quo because the NFL
doesn't make announcements along the way
once a guy suspended and in this in this
year plus mode they won't say Oh NFL
spokesman says this guy failed the test
that he suspended for another gear
because he's in that Commissioner
discretion period so you don't ever hear
about these things you will never hear
about Oh Justin Blackmon failed another
test it's just a matter of a reporter
kind of checked again so so with Gordon
there was no announcement to be had here
because again he's in that period of but
when he fails the test the Commissioner
can just he has a discretion how he
wants to handle it now if you continue
to fail that and continue to show that
you're not going to straighten yourself
out here as far as the ruler concern
then they're not going to reinstate you
but it's in that period where there's no
protocol for okay this triggers that
this triggers this and there's no
announcement so that's why kinda in that
boat I know it's a lot of gray area I
get it and we're used to a a league
where there's a lot of rules and a lot
of fish happens and then boom this
happens but he's in that that that gray
area right mode that's why yeah it does
seem though Mike like with every passing
year the NFL is kind of making this
stuff up a little bit more as they go
and that they're a little bit more
flexible we're talking with Mike Guerra
follow of FS 1 or as we say in the old
country garofalo you know what i mean so
III got both pronunciations in there
mike did you see the UM he's the one
that broke the story by the way about
josh gordon tested positive and zell TMZ
video uh yeah I've seen which one I've
seen a couple of them no the one the one
where he says he's living with von
Miller he admits he's been the same bar
five or six nights in a row I should not
be laughing about that I don't think but
that goes back to my whole sensitive
thing anyway um is there at you know
just watching that video my gut tells me
there's no shot that he gets signed by a
team this year what are you hearing
thinking whatever your gut and the gut
of many people in the league and some
people in his in his circle that I've
been talking to I have I was just
talking to an NFL GM about something
unrelated on I just have a Saturday
night and I brought up Manziel for
whatever reason and he said you know
dude I think I think it's done I think
he had done right now and it's just
speculation I mean the other kid could
turn himself around but on a number of
fronts right now for Manziel it doesn't
look real good and I've had people close
to him who say you know he just he can't
stop and we keeps telling them you know
you need to stop you need to turn this
thing around for your career sake for
your health take and he just want any
discontinuing to to to go out there and
party and i'm not i'm not saying that
you can't go out enjoy yourself but when
you've got your agent has fired you
or terminated his relationship with you
and been publicly announced it and your
father is out there saying he's
concerned for your safety doesn't think
you're going to survive if you don't get
to help and you continue to do these
things I think that speaks a lot of the
people around the league and you know he
was he was good he was good in spurts
with the Browns but it's not like he lit
the world on fire so it's not like
people are saying you know compared to
Josh Gordon who led the league in
receiving in 2013 uh and you've got
Mandela who again at times has shown
it's not much people are clamoring for
the chance to get this gal we can
straighten them out at this point so I
think it's very bleak right now I also
believe that uh that there will be a
suspension coming for him in some form
or fashion i I've mentioned that the NFL
has been watching Manziel on multiple
fronts recently and if he avoids any
suspension for anything at all I will be
very very fragile Wow another suspension
this one potentially for Johnny Manziel
Mike great stuff good job breaking that
story yesterday and breaking it down
here on the Dan Patrick show thanks so
much you got it handsome haha nice the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience